Ja.
Schön.
Mhm.
Alles klar.
Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Yülle Östjelik Baran.
Ich bin hier auf dieser Situation als Assistenzärztin tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Mhm.
Gerne.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Mhm.
Ja, super.
Und ich werde als erstes ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Mhm.
Als erstes, wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin, ähm, ich bin die Gerlinde Schmidt.
Gerlinde Schmidt.
Mhm.
Frau Schmidt, könnten Sie Ihre Vorname buchstabieren?
Mein Vornamen buchstabieren.
Ja, genau.
G-E-R-L-I-N-T-E.
Gerlinde.
Ja.
Am Ende? R.
Nein.
E.
Noa E.
Okay.
Mhm.
Okay, danke schön.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ähm, ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
60.
1. April 1962 geworden.
1. April 1962.
60.
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,78 m.
Wieder Ihre Stimmung.
Entschuldigung.
Kein Problem, alles gut.
Ja, ja, ja.
Wie wie wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m groß.
1.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Hm, was wiege ich?
Ungefähr 70 kg.
70.
Hm.
Und wie ist Ihr Hausarztname?
Wie sind Sie?
Hausarztname nicht, sondern wie ist der Name vom Hausarzt?
Ja, okay.
Ähm, das ist der Doktor Mirza.
Mirza.
Mhm.
M-I-R-Z-A.
Danke schön.
Mhm.
Ähm, und Rauschen mit.
Was hat Sie sonst geführt?
Ähm, wie Sie sehen, das hier genäht jetzt, sehen Sie, da ist eine Naht, Trich.
Und ich bin gestern, bin ich im Bad, wo es los geworden.
Und bin mit dem Kopf auf den Waschbecken gestört und mit dem Kopf auf den Waschbecken gekommen.
Gestern.
Ja?
Ja, gestern Abend, gestern Abend.
Also spät, ich lag schon im Bett und dann bin ich aufgestanden, weil ich noch mal auf die Toilette wollte.
Mhm.
Und dann bin ich, ähm, und dann bin ich, ähm, auf einmal bin ich bewusst los geworden und dann bin ich mit dem Kopf auf das Waschbecken gekneilt.
Wie lange dauert, wie lange dauert, wie lange dauert, wie lange dauert, wissen Sie?
Nein, nochmal, das war falsch.
Noch mal, richtig sein.
Wie lange dauert, sind Sie unmächtig?
Oder?
Wie lange hat das gedauert?
Oder wie lange waren Sie unmächtig?
Ja, okay, wie lange waren Sie unmächtig?
Na ja, also mein Mann hat den Knall gehört.
Mhm.
Er hat gesagt, ein, weiß ich nicht, ne, ein halbe Minute vielleicht.
Halbe Minute.
Er hat nicht auf die Uhr geguckt, gefühlt.
Okay, äh, und in Merchseite sind Sie hingepallen?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin mit dem Kopf auf das Waschbecken und dann bin ich irgendwie, ich glaube, auf die linke Seite.
Mhm.
Okay, haben Sie, äh, haben Sie Brutzschmerzen, Atemnot oder Kusten oder Herzreisen bemerkt?
Gehabt jetzt gestern, meinen Sie, ob ich das gestern gehabt habe?
Ja, gestern oder heute?
Ja, oder heute noch, ja, verstehe.
Also gestern habe ich keine Brutzschmerzen gehabt, auch keine Kopfschmerzen, gar nichts,
aber ich habe sehr starke Bauchschmerzen gehabt.
Deswegen bin ich auch auf die Toilette gegangen.
Und ich war noch nicht, auf der Toilette hatte noch keinen, hat mich noch nicht hingesetzt.
Da bin ich schon bewusst los geworden, aber ich habe sehr, sehr starke Bauchschmerzen gehabt, die habe ich jetzt auch noch.
Bauchschmerzen.
Haben Sie heute auch Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, das ist so im Oberbauch, hier so im Oberbauch, so in Richtung Magen, aber es zieht so mehr in den Unterbauch, da tut es am stärksten weh, im Unterbauch.
Unterbauch, heute.
Gestern auch, das war unerträgliche Schmerzen hatte ich gestern.
Okay, äh, und ist Ihnen übel oder schmittig?
Nein, schwindelig war mir nicht, schwindelig war mir nicht, mir ist jetzt auch nicht schwindelig.
Und so richtig übel ist, habe ich auch nicht, ich habe keine Übelkeit.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Und wie stark die Bauchschmerzen auf einer Skala Form 1 bis 10, wenn 1 leichter, sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen sind?
Wie schätzen Sie ein?
Ähm, ja, über 10.
Das sehen.
Das kann man nicht in Worte fassen, so stark waren meine Schmerzen.
Das war schon sehr, sehr schlimm, waren unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Unerträglich.
Okay, äh, wie verhalten sich die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit?
Was meinen Sie dann?
Verschlechter oder verhindert eigentlich?
Nein, ist eher etwas weniger geworden, sonst wäre ich ja in der Nacht schon, also nein, ist eher weniger geworden.
Weniger.
Aber immer noch stark, aber nicht mehr so stark wie gestern Abend.
Haben Sie einen Tablette angenommen, deswegen?
Gestern.
Gestern oder heute?
Nein, heute habe ich ja in der Notaufnahme Schmerzmittel gekriegt.
Ihre Kollegin hat mir doch eben Schmerzmittel gegeben, also Infusion.
Okay.
Und würde ich sagen, strahlen die Bauchschmerzen in anderer Körperregion auf?
Das ist so mehr wirklich Unterbauch, der komplette Unterbauch, und man zieht es hoch hier bis in den Magen.
Wo würde ich sagen, ich kann nicht genau sagen, das ist mehr rechts, mehr links, das ist der ganze Unterbauch.
Und Sie haben nicht erbrochen, richtig?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Und ist Ihnen irgendwo eine Schwellung, Rötung oder Überwarmung aufgefallen?
Wo?
Wo oder?
Ja, wo, was meinen Sie, wo aufgefallen?
Ja, wo aufgefallen.
Wo?
Am ganzen Körper oder Bauch?
Also irgendwo.
Ah, irgendwo.
Nein, nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen irgendwo.
Ja, ist Ihnen einen Blutschupur aufgefallen?
Irgendwo.
Blut im Stuhl, meinen Sie?
Blutschupur, ja, also Bluterguss oder was, wissen Sie.
Ach Sie meinen Bluterguss?
Ja.
Bluterguss, nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Bluterguss habe ich nicht.
Ich dachte Sie meinen Blut im Stuhl.
Ja.
Noch was?
Und könnten Sie diese Bauchschmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ich meine Stehhände und polikartige, wie schätzen Sie an?
Weiß ich nicht, genau, das sind so brennende Schmerzen, die sind eigentlich immer da.
Also die sind eigentlich nicht kulikartig, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, was ist kulikartig überhaupt?
Also, nicht, diese Schmerzen sind nicht immer da.
Manchmal da und wieder, ab und zu, ich meine, polikartig.
Und klarfertig, das kann sein, können wir sagen.
Noch mal erklären, polikartig bedeutet, dass die Schmerzen kommen und gehen.
Das reicht schon.
Kommt und gehen.
Okay, danke Schmerz.
Und noch etwas.
Und wie ist Ihr Schlaf und Appetit?
Naja, jetzt bin ich krank, jetzt habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Also jetzt kann man von Appetit nicht reden, aber normalerweise habe ich kein Problem mit Appetit.
Letzter Zeit ist mir auch gefallen, dass es ein bisschen schlechter geworden ist, aber ich kann Ihnen nicht genau sagen, woran das liegt.
Okay, und wie verhalten Sie sich die Schmerzen beim Bewegung, also im Stähnen beim Liegen?
Ja, ich habe das ja erst seit gestern Abend, das ist immer da.
Ja, immer da.
Okay, danke schön.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Beim Stuhlgang, ich habe ja gedacht, wenn ich gestern Stuhlgang habe, wird es besser, aber ich habe ja gar keinen Stuhlgang gehabt.
Ich bin ja bewusstlos geworden, bevor ich Stuhlgang hatte gestern.
Und in letzter Zeit ist es eher wechselhaft.
Also ist es mal, ist es dünn, mal ist es fest, ist es eher wechselhaft in letzter Zeit.
Und wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Normalerweise nicht.
Ich habe Schmerzen gehabt, können Sie schlafen, wenn Sie Schmerzen haben.
Okay, danke schön.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche Erkrankungen vor Erkrankungen?
Eigentlich nicht, eigentlich habe ich keine Erkrankungen.
Ich habe auch keine Medikamente, die ich regelmäßig einnehme.
Aber bei Bedarf nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein, bei Bedarf.
Sie meinen, wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe?
Ja, genau, das dann sein.
Ja, aber das kommt einmal im Jahr vor oder so.
Wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe, nehme ich mal eine Paracetamol,
aber sonst nehme ich eigentlich nichts regelmäßiges ein.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Ich muss das fragen.
Wie viel Dosier hat?
Wie viel Dosis?
Wie viel Milligramm?
Wie viel Milligramm geht?
Oder welche Dosis?
Welche Dosis?
Genau, oder wie ist die Dosierung?
Aber das würde ich patinlich fragen, das ist zu kompliziert.
Wie viel Milligramm oder welche Dosis?
Welche Dosierung?
Ja, ganz normale Parazite, Mutterpletten, 500 Milligramm.
Würden Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt oder operiert, Frau Schmidt?
Ich habe zwei Kinder und beide waren ein Kaiserschnitt, sonst bin ich nicht operiert worden.
Wann?
Meine eine Tochter ist geboren 1993 und die andere ist geboren 1998.
1998.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie eine Allergie gegen etwas oder haben Sie eine Unverträgliche gegen Darufsmittel?
Ja, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Allergien und ich habe auch keine Nahrungsmittel und Verträglichkeiten.
Ja, aber ich versuche trotzdem Gluten, aber das ist keine Allergie, oder?
Ist das eine Allergie?
Ich versuche wenig Gluten zu essen.
Ja, das kann unverkretlich sein.
Ah, okay. Also eine richtige Unverträglichkeit nicht, aber ich versuche Glutenarm zu essen.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Weil es gesund ist, ne?
Ja, natürlich.
Und wie ist Ihr Impfstatt?
Was für ein Impfstatt?
Sind Ihre Impfungen komplett?
Welche Impfungen?
Gegen Corona oder Kindererkrankungen?
Kindererkrankungen?
Ja, das ist, denke ich, als Kind gemacht worden.
Und Covid bin ich zweimal geimpft?
Zweimal.
Einmal war ich krank und zweimal geimpft?
Okay, danke schön.
Rauchen Sie, wenn ja, was rauchen Sie und wie viel verdacht man?
Ich habe als Jugendliche mal so 20 Jahre lang geraucht.
Und ich rauche schon seit langem nicht mehr.
Okay.
20 Jahre lang haben Sie geraucht?
Ungefähr 20 Jahre.
Ja, okay, wie viel?
Eine halbe Packung.
Und wann haben Sie mit Zigaretten aufgehören?
Noch mal, wiederholen den Satz, der war falsch.
Wann haben Sie mit Zigaretten aufgehören?
Geht nicht.
Wann haben Sie aufgehört?
Genau.
Ja, sagen wir mal, ich habe mit 16 Jahren angefangen zu rauchen
und ich habe vielleicht mit, keine Ahnung, 36 aufgehört oder so.
36.
Das ist schon sehr lange, also ich suche ungefähr vor 30 Jahren,
habe ich aufgehört zu rauchen, ungefähr.
Ungefähr, ja, danke super.
Vielen Dank.
Für Ihre Gesundheit.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Ja, okay.
Und fraue ich mich, ich muss das fragen, bitte nehmen Sie persönlich.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder haben Sie ein Drogen probiert?
Ein Drogen probiert geht nicht.
Oder haben Sie mal Drogen probiert?
Ja, schon mal.
Drogen ist mehr Zeit immer.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Drogen probiert?
Ja.
Nein, habe ich nicht, aber ich nehme immer so Vitamine.
Sind das auch Drogen?
Nein.
Und 3D-Sport?
Na ja, wissen Sie, das kann man nicht Sport nennen.
Ich fahre zum Bäcker immer mit dem Fahrrad.
Das ist alles, was ich mache an Sport.
Fahrrad.
Ja, ich fahre mit dem Fahrrad.
Ja, zum Bäcker zum Brot kaufen halt, wie oft gibt man zum Bäcker Brot kaufen?
Morgens, wenn ich zum Bäcker Brötchen kaufen gehe oder Brot,
dann mache ich das mit dem Fahrrad,
aber das ist alles, was ich an Sport mache.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Und brauche mit Leben Ihre Eltern, ne?
Meine Eltern sind leider verstorben.
Okay, tut mir leid, mein Beileid.
Danke.
Woran haben Ihre Eltern gestorben?
Noch mal.
Woran?
Sind gestorben, nicht haben.
Ja, woran sind Ihre Eltern gestorben?
Woran sind Ihre Eltern gestorben?
Ja, meine Mutter hatte leider Krebs.
Mein Vater, das er hat lange gelebt, er hatte einen natürlichen Tod.
Welche Krebs wissen Sie?
Ja, Sie hat, das weiß ich nicht so genau, ehrlich gesagt.
Das war schon nachher Endstadium.
Primarius war nicht so ganz klar.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und wie war als Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter war jung, sie war 67, als sie gestorben ist.
67.
Und Ihre Vater?
War in 82.
82.
Okay.
Und woran ist Ihre Vater gestorben?
Der ist an einem ganz normalen Alterstod gestorben.
Er war, er ist einfach alt geworden.
Das war jetzt einfach...
Geschwäsche oder was?
Altersschwäsche, ja.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester, ja.
Okay, ist Ihre Schwester gesund?
Schwester, nicht Geschwester?
Ja, Schwester.
Meine Schwester ist Gott sei Dank gesund, ja.
Also noch ist nichts bekannt.
Ach so, Entschuldigung, nein, sie hat, sie ist etwas agipös und hat Diabetes.
Stimmt, sie hat Diabetes und Bluthochdruck neuerlich entneuerlich entwickelt, ja.
Bluthochdruck.
Und wie ist Ihre Schwester?
Bitte.
Wie alt ist Ihre Schwester?
Meine Schwester ist 62.
62.
Danke schön.
Brauchst Sie mit, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Und Sie haben zwei Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Töchter.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Meine Töchter sind gesund, ja.
Ja, super.
Leben Sie mit Ehemann?
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Ehemann zusammen?
Ja.
Ich lebe mit Ihrem Ehemann zusammen.
Danke schön.
Wir sind jetzt am Ende des Unseramgesprächs,
vielen Dank für Ihr Mitarbeit.
Und wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe,
Sie haben seit gestern nach Kopfhahn
auf den Kopf aufgestoßen.
Noch mal. Ich habe nichts verstanden.
Sie haben seit gestern nach den Kopfhahn aufgestoßen.
Seit gestern nach.
Dünnerkischam, dann beri kafa'nizi
shere'le rob'e vuriyorsunuz, dj.
Kafanizi vurduktan sorna nas dijan.
Nach dem.
Nach dem Sie gestern abend.
Nach dem, geçmisch, nach dem,
olduktan sorna.
Nach dem Sie gestern auf dem
Kopf auf dem Kopf aufgestoßen.
Hab'n zee kud.
Ja.
Also seit gestern.
Nein, nicht seit gestern.
Dünn, dj. beri djosnuz hala.
Okay, aber...
Ja, alles klar.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Seit gestern haben sie
Unterbauchschmerzen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, diese Schmerzen sind unverträglich.
Ich habe nicht gesagt unverträglich.
Was ist unverträglich?
Unerträgliche.
Unerträglich ist richtig.
Aber was ist unverträglich?
Unverträglich?
Ja, ja.
Diese Schmerzen sind unerträglich oder sehr stark.
Ja, und sie beschreiben als brennende,
nicht kollikartige Schmerzen.
Und noch etwas.
Und ich glaube,
das ist etwas.
Und die Barrenummähtige,
ich glaube, 1 halbe Stunde.
Nein, 1 halbe Minute.
1 halbe Stunde ist zu viel.
Ja, genau, 1 halbe Minute.
Und noch etwas.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist etwas.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinfügen?
Nein, Sie haben das so geschildert, wie es stimmt.
Gestern Abend habe ich meinen Kopf aufgestoßen.
Ich hatte sehr starke Unterbauchschmerzen.
Und ich bin bewusstlos geworden.
Ja, okay.
Also ich würde sie als erstes körperlich untersuchen.
Und ich würde ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und als ein paar Untersuchungen veranlasst,
ich meine als erstes EKG verschreiben.
Und noch etwas.
Also Ultrasonographie des Abdomens.
Bauch Ultrasonographie, können wir sagen.
Ultraschall des Abdomens, ja.
Und gegebenenfalls ich würde CT des Abdomens durchführen.
CT.
Ja, okay.
Und ich werde Sie rechtseitig informieren.
Ich werde Sie beruhigen.
Okay, das ist aber noch viel, was gemacht werden muss.
Ja, aber ich muss das mal.
Muss ich hier bleiben? Muss ich bleiben?
Ja, natürlich. Um eine genaue Diagnose zu bestimmen.
Ja.
Ein paar Stunden hierbleiben.
Kann ich nach Hause?
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich werde Sie rechtseitig informieren.
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.
Ich möchte Sie eine andere Frage.
Hab Sie Ihre Stülferänderung bemerkt, außer Obstipation?
Ja, in letzter Zeit habe ich das Gefühl gehabt,
dass es etwas schmerzhaft war und immer so wechselt.
Es war mal fest und dann mal dünn so.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Hausfrau.
Habt ihr die Stülferänderung bemerkt?
Was meinen Sie mit Farbveränderungen?
Manchmal brauche ich manchmal Rote.
Ich habe sie bemerkt in Stül.
Wenn Sie mich so fragen, war das manchmal dunkel,
manchmal brauche ich das.
Rauschen, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen oder so?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir das einbilde, aber ich habe etwas abgenommen.
Hatten Sie früher dann Spiegelung gemacht?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Oder Magenspiegelung?
Hab ich auch noch nie gehabt.
Schwitzen Sie in der Nacht oder haben Sie Fieber bemerkt?
Ich habe keinen Fieber.
Und Schwitzen ist mir auch nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe das gemerkt, aber seit meinem 50. Lebensjahr schwitzt sich nachts.
Das ist wegen meinem Klimakterium.
Eigentlich müsste das besser werden.
Ich frage mich, haben Sie bemerkt, dass besonders macht,
die Beschwerden verschlimmert?
Noch einmal.
Den ersten Satz habe ich nicht verstanden.
Wann verschlimmert sich das?
Sie essen gerne Brot.
Sie haben zwei Mal gesagt beim Fahrradfahren.
Das heißt, Sie haben bemerkt, dass Ihre Beschwerden mit Brot essen.
Nachungsabhängig ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nicht, dass es mir aufgefallen ist, dass es dadurch mehr wird.
Ich habe nicht sehr viel Brot wegen dem Gluten.
Das ist eher für meine Familie.
Ich würde gerne fragen, ob Sie sich ernähren?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Sie essen viel Fleisch?
Nein, ich esse nicht so viel Fleisch.
Ich versuche weniger Brot zu essen, aber ich esse viel Gemüse.
Fleisch ist nicht so viel, man soll es nicht gesund sein.
Ich versuche weniger Kohlenhydrate und Zucker zu essen.
Ich ernähre mich so.
Seit wann?
Immer.
Ich versuche immer, meine Figur zu achten.
Danke.
Wie fühlen Sie sich heutzutage?
Zum Beispiel, wie fühlen Sie Müde, Erschöpfe?
Sie meinen, wie fühlen Sie sich heute?
Heute?
Heute darf man nicht fragen, man muss immer sagen, wie fühlen Sie sich heute?
Heutzutage.
Heutzutage heißt, in dieser Zeit, in der Zeit.
Heute?
Heute ist es in letzter Zeit.
Heutzutage sagt man nicht, bitte nicht sagen.
Heutzutage heißt, wo sind Sie?
Heute ist es in letzter Zeit.
In letzter Zeit ist gut.
Und sich, nicht wie fühlen Sie sich in letzter Zeit?
Das wäre ein perfekter Satz.
In letzter Zeit?
Ich bin vielleicht etwas müde, aber das kann ich mir natürlich auch einbilden.
Also eigentlich geht es mir nicht in letzter Zeit viel schlechter als sonst, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen stellen.
Ich möchte Ihre Bewusstsein verloren fragen.
Ihre Bewusstlosigkeit.
Haben Sie vor dem Anfall oder nach dem Anfall,
welches Symptome erinnern Sie sich?
Falsch, geht nicht.
Jim Lea Jan-Schweinem, haben Sie vor dem Anfall oder nach dem Anfall Symptome bemerkt?
Erinnern Sie sich, erinnern Sie sich, ich weiß, was das ist.
Erinnern Sie sich an das, vor dem Anfall,
was passiert ist?
Können Sie sich erinnern, was genau vor dem Anfall und nach dem Anfall passiert ist?
Ja, sehr gut. Aber nicht Anfall, sondern am besten ist Bewusstlosigkeit.
Können Sie sich an das, was vor dem Anfall und nach dem Anfall erinnern?
Ja, sehr gut.
An das genau vor dem Anfall, ja schon.
Ich kann mich nur noch erinnern, dass ich ins Bad gegangen bin.
An alles andere kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Ja, ich stärke Bauchschmerzen, aber...
Daran kann ich mich erinnern, natürlich.
Ich hatte starke Bauchschmerzen, ich lag schon im Bett, ich wollte schlafen, konnte nicht.
Ich hatte so starke Bauchschmerzen, dass ich aufgestanden bin.
Ich bin auf die Toilette gegangen und danach kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Haben Sie gekrampft?
Bitte?
Gekrampft.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, was passiert ist.
Aber mein Mann hat gesagt, ich habe nicht gekrampft.
Okay.
Ihre Bauchschmerzen haben Sie grüßlich aufgefallen?
Sind die Bauchschmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ich geht jetzt.
Nein.
Ich hatte gestern Tag über schon gemerkt,
irgendwie geht mein Bauch nicht so gut.
Und in der Nacht ist das dann richtig schlimm geworden.
Gib das Beispiel zum Austauschen für die Schmerzen.
Erinnern Sie sich.
Nein, ich habe das ja zum ersten Mal.
Ja, also Sie haben gesagt, nach dem Kopf aufgestoßen habe.
Ja, das ist ein Auslöse.
Auslöse ist Bauchschmerzen, Stärke Bauchschmerzen.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe eine Prodromyphase,
aber die Patine hat gesagt,
keine Prodromysyptome.
Richtig, Herr Kollege.
Prodromy ist genau so eine Symptome,
oder einfach die bestimmten Sachen,
die quasi darauf hindeuten,
dass etwas passieren wird.
Das heißt, Schwindel wackele ich auf den Beinen.
Prodromy ist fachspezifisch.
Haben Sie gemerkt, dass Sie bewusstlos werden?
Zum Beispiel Schwindel geworden, wackele ich auf den Beinen?
Das sind ja Prodromy.
Was sind Prodromy?
Anzeichen?
Wahnsinntome, oder?
Ja, Wahnsinntome, Anzeichen, dass Sie bewusstlos werden.
Haben Sie das gemerkt?
Genau.
Nein, habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Wirklich, plötzlich.
Ich hatte Schmerzen, und plötzlich muss das passiert sein.
Sie haben gesagt, andere Kollegen
hat Medikamente verabreicht.
Ja, ich bin ja jetzt in die Notaufnahme,
und dann habe ich gleich eine Nadel gelegt bekommen,
weil ich so starke Schmerzen habe,
und dann habe ich Medikamente gekriegt.
Was ist das nicht?
Unsere Kollegen hat bei ihnen
Blutabgenomen und Instaborgeschicht.
Ja, hat sie.
Ich sehe Schütul und Wasalas'
Angenomen, hat...
Bitte?
Ganz, hat er, hat der Kollege?
Ja.
Bei ihnen, für die Labor.
Stuhl- und Urinprobe.
Ist Stuhl- und Urinprobe bei Ihnen abgenommen worden?
Sagen Sie das mal.
Unsere Kollegen hat bei ihnen für die Labor
Urin- und Stuhlprobe abgenommen.
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, ihre Gewicht abgenommen haben.
Sie haben gesagt, ihre Gewicht abgenommen.
Wie viel Kilogramm, in welchem Zeitraum
haben Sie abgenommen?
Ach ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich kann es nicht genau sagen.
Ich merke, ich wiege mich auch nicht regelmäßig.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich mich nicht regelmäßig habe.
dass meine Kleider etwas weiter geworden sind.
So irgendwie in den letzten drei Monaten, würde ich sagen.
Hatten Sie seit Beginn, ich herbauchschmerzen?
Einmal Stuhlgang oder gehen Wind ab?
Gehen Winde ab.
Winde.
Nein, also Blähungen habe ich nicht.
Und Stuhlgang auf der Toilette?
Hab ich ja gesagt, unterschiedlich.
Mal braun, mal sehr dunkel.
Mal weich, mal dick.
Jetzt, als ich diese starken Bauchschmerzen hatte,
hatte ich auch nicht viel etwas Stuhlgang.
Okay, Blähungen haben Sie gesagt.
Und aufstossen oder so brennen.
Hab ich auch nicht.
Können wir als als geschebte Anfang?
Ja, mir ist egal.
Ja, gerne.
Hallo.
Schönen guten Tag Frau Doktor.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Darf ich Ihnen vorstellen?
Wir gerne, ja.
Danke schön.
Frau Schimit ist eine 60-Jährige Patientin.
Diese ist heute Morgen bei uns wegen
seit gestern aufgetretenen Bestehende
heftige Unterbauchschmerzen vorgestellt hat.
Die Patientin berichtet, dass die Schmerzen,
nachdem sie den Kopf auf den Waschbecken aufgestoßen,
aufgetreten sei.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe zuerst die Schmerzen gehabt.
Sie hat zuerst die Schmerzen gehabt und hat dann,
als sie mit den Schmerzen auf die Toilette gegangen ist,
den Kopf aufgestoßen.
Nicht seitdem aufstoßen die Schmerzen.
Schmerzen hat sich vorher schon gehabt.
Vorher.
Okay.
Dass die Schmerzen nach auf die Toilette gegangen sind,
aufgetreten sei.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Was würde ich sagen?
Die Patientin hatte starke Schmerzen,
Unterbauchschmerzen, haben Sie ja schon gesagt, seit gestern?
Okay.
Sie haben sich aufgetreten sind, auf die Toilette gegangen
und ist dann bewusstlos geworden und hat sich dabei,
hat sich dabei den Kopf angestoßen am Waschbecken.
Okay.
Noch mal wiederholen Sie bitte das, was ich gesagt habe.
Die Patientin berichtet,
berichtet, dass die Schmerzen,
okay, ich muss, ich muss...
Sie haben doch schon gesagt, der erste Satz war doch schon gut.
Sie hat seit gestern heftigste bestehende Unterbauchschmerzen.
Ja, genau.
Wir sind gestern erstmalig aufgetreten,
erst abends, mit dem, als sie die Schmerzen bemerkt hat,
ist sie auf die Toilette gegangen
und ist dabei bewusstlos geworden und den Kopf aufgestoßen.
Ja, okay, okay, okay.
Noch mal wiederholen.
Ja, okay, wiederholen.
Und die Patientin berichtet,
sie auf die Toilette gegangen
sein.
Das sie auf die Toilette gegangen sind.
Ja.
Und sie erwähnt nach dem,
sie den Kopf auf den Waschbecken aufgestoßen haben.
Ja, ja.
Sie haben die Toilette gegangen.
Sie haben die Kopf auf den Waschbecken aufgestoßen.
Warum?
Warum aufgestoßen?
Weil sie erst die bewusstlosigkeit haben.
Ja, ja.
Sie haben die Toilette gegangen.
Sie haben die Toilette bewusstlos geworden.
Ja, und hat den Kopf,
während der Bewusstlosigkeit, weil sie bewusstlos geworden ist,
hat sie den Kopf auf den Waschbecken aufgestoßen.
Das ist gar nicht so wichtig, dass sie den Kopf aufgestoßen haben.
Wichtig ist, dass sie bewusstlos geworden ist.
Das heißt noch mal, die Patientin hat seit gestern
heftigste bla bla bla bla bla.
Ja, und als die Schmerzen aufgetreten sind,
ist sie auf die Toilette gegangen
bevor sie Stuhlgang hatte.
Hatte sie alles nicht.
Sie ist bewusstlos geworden.
Und da hat dabei, das heißt schon, während der Bewusstlosigkeit,
und hat dabei den Kopf am Waschbecken aufgestoßen.
Ja, ich habe so...
Wir fahren ganz von vorne an.
Ja, okay.
Aber das für mich ist einfach.
Einfaches Set, wenn ich so kompliziert bin.
Ich mache die ganz einfache Set.
Also, ich bin von vorne an.
Ja, okay.
Fraschumit ist eine 60-Jährige Patientin,
die sich heute Morgen bei uns wegen des gestern aufgetretenes
und hat viele unter bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Die Patientin berichtet,
dass sie auf die Toilette gegangen sind.
Nein, Sie sind ein Mensch.
ist, wie kisch. Ja, okay. Dass die Patientin gestern Abend, nicht
heute, gestern muss noch die Zeit sein, dass die gestern Abend auf die Toilette
gegangen ist. Ja. Und sie den Kopf... Ja, mit dem Kopf, sie ist bewusstlos geworden.
Ja, sie ist bewusstlos geworden. Ja. Dann sie den Kopf auf den Waschbecken
tauscht. Ja, sie ist bewusstlos geworden und hat den Kopf auf den Waschbecken
aufgestoßen. Ganz einfache Sätze. Ja, okay. Sehr gut. Super. Das geht.
Sie klagte über Syncope? Nein, klagte über Syncope geht nicht. Man klagt nur über
Schmerzen. Klagte... Warum? Geht nicht. Klagte heißt Agio Biel Mario. Geht nicht.
Sie hatte eine Syncope? Sie hatte, sie hatte eine Syncope. Ja. Sie ist gestern
bewusstlos geworden. Ja, sie hatte gestern eine Syncope. Der Obererziehen kann man
sagen Syncope, ne? Weil die Obererziehen weiß ja Fachbedarf. Die Patientin hatte
sehr starke Schmerzen, ist auf die Toilette gegangen und hatte eine Syncope.
Oder ist syncopiert, ja. Und während der Syncope hat sie den Kopf auf den
Waschbecken aufgestoßen. Aber egal, das reicht jetzt. Sie können weiter machen.
Okay. Und die erwähnte, sie, sie für halbe Minute, halbe Minute
ohmmetig gewesen seid. Und man muss nicht sagen, immer sie erwähnt, da muss man
nicht sagen. Sie ist Syncopiert. Die Syncope hat eine halbe Minute gedauert.
Okay. Okay. Teilz Sie mit, dass die Schmerzen,
die von Zain auf einer Schmerzskala sind und die Schmerzen da sind und die
Fragen nach Brustschmerzen, Atmung, Schmusten oder Emesis würden von der
Patientin fernal. Und fernal sind der Patientin die Folgenden
Begleitzentome aufgefallen.
Schwindelig? Ja, noch nicht. Nein, Schwendel noch nie aufgetreten.
Nein, noch nie Schwendel gehabt. Übelkeit. Auch noch nie. Sie haben gefragt, ob ich
Übelkeit habe und ich habe gesagt, nein, ich habe keine Übelkeit. Sie haben mich
gefragt, ob ich Schwendel habe und ich habe gesagt, ich habe nie Schwendel gehabt.
Nein.
Dünke Sturgang, aber.
Dünke Sturgang, ich habe nicht gehört.
Ja, okay. Die vegetative Annamnese ist eine
Perlikisa of Inappetens wegen Schmerzen, Insomnia auf wegen Schmerzen.
Und Wasalasen ist normal. Sturgang ist
in letzter Zeit wechselhaft. Wechselhaftig.
Ja, manche. Wechselhaft gibt es nicht. Wechselhaft.
Ja, ist schon ein Adjektiv. Okay, manchmal testen, manchmal bünden.
Und sie leiden keine
Vorerkrankungen. Leider keine Vorerkrankungen.
Sie nehmen.
Und sagt nicht, die Leide an Vorerkrankungen gibt es nicht. Man sagt
eigentlich, sie hat keine Vorerkrankungen. Sie habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Sie habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Sie.
Obweine. Nicht, weil. Also nicht, sie leidet einfach, sondern man sagt,
sie habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Ja, sie habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Und sie nehmen Paracetamol bei Bedarf ein.
Und sie, wo der Zweimal,
Sezerian, Zektio, Sezeria.
Sezeria. Nein.
Sexio, Cesaris.
Sexio, Cesaris. Ja, oder Kaiserschnitt.
Kaiserschnitt.
Ja, oder Sektio reicht auch schon, Herr.
Sektio. Genau.
Okay.
Und es, ja, es wurde bei ihr zweimal Sektio durchgeführt.
Bei den Geburt, kann man sagen.
Bei den Geburt, dann wurde zweimal eine Sektio durchgeführt.
Ja.
Und sie, sie habe als Jugend,
also 20 Jahre lang,
sie habe in der Jugend,
gen Schlägtemeg, oder sie habe als Jugendliche.
Als Jugendliche.
Oder sie hat früher alles weglassen,
sie hat früher, oder sie hat vor 30 Jahren 20 Jahre lang geraucht.
Kann man auch sagen.
Sie haben vor 30 Jahren, circa 20 Jahre lang geraucht.
Ja, okay. Sie haben früher, 20 Jahre lang,
halbe Packung geraucht.
Ja, wie viel sind das? Wie viel Packiers sind das?
Eine halbe Packung.
Wie viel Packiers sind das?
Packiers.
Yes.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Ich sehe, ich sehe.
Ich sehe.
Sie hat 10.
10.
10 Packiers, sie hat 10 Packiers geraucht.
Kann man sagen.
Es reicht auch schon.
Sie hat 10 Packiers geraucht,
aber schon seit 20, 30 Jahren nicht mehr.
Ja, genau.
Sie, Sie haben bis vor 24 Jahre
10 Packungsjahre geraucht.
10 Packiers geraucht, nicht Packungsjahre.
10 Packiers geraucht.
Ja, gedauft. Richtig?
10 Päck hier ist, mehr nicht, 10 Päck hier ist geraucht.
Hier ist es geraucht.
Genau, kann man auch sagen, sehr gut, ja.
Ja. Und Alkohol und Drogen konsum wurden vernein.
Sie treiben Sportfahrradfahren.
Nein, das geht gar nicht.
Ja, Sie fahren Fahrrad oder?
Ja, das kann ich sagen.
Sie treiben nicht regelmäßig.
Sie treiben nicht regelmäßig Fahrradfahrrad.
Das ist ja kein Sport.
Wenn man zum Bäcker fährt und Brötchen holt mit dem Fahrrad,
das ist kein Sport.
Außer täglich Fahrradfahren zum Bäcker treibt sie kein Sport.
Sagen Sie das mal.
Ja, okay.
Nein, wiederholen Sie das.
Okay.
Außer täglich mit dem Fahrrad zum Bäcker fahren treibt sie kein Sport.
Ja, treibt sie kein Sport, aber zum Bäcker fahren.
Noch mal. Beide setzen komplett Grammatikalsch falsch.
Ja, okay.
Sie treiben keinen Sport.
Ja.
Aber Sie fahren täglich mit dem Fahrrad zum Bäcker.
Mit dem Fahrrad zum Bäcker.
Sie fährt täglich mit dem Fahrrad zum Bäcker.
Ja, Sie fährt täglich mit dem Fahrrad zum Bäcker.
Sonst treibt sie kein Sport.
Sie fährt täglich mit dem Fahrrad zum Bäcker.
Okay, super.
Und Ihr Impfstatus, also Kindererkrankungen, ist komplett.
Sie ist zweimal gegen COVID geimpft.
Und noch, Ihr...
Einmal genießen, ne? Sie hat gesagt, dass sie krank war einmal.
Sie ist zweimal geimpft und einmal genießen.
Einmal genießen.
Also, Atlatmuschastallöre, genießen. Also zweimal geimpft und einmal geimpft.
Ja.
Und Ihre Mutter ist an Krebs gestorben.
Aber sie weiß nicht, warum.
Oder welcher Krebs?
Welcher Krebs.
Und Ihr Vater ist an alter Geschwäche gestorben.
An alter Geschwäche gestorben.
Und Sie haben eine Schwester und Ihre Schwester leidet an Adipositas.
Adipositas.
Und Diabetes mellitus und Arterialpipertoni.
Und Sie ist Hausfrau und verheiratet.
Sie hat zwei Tochter.
Und Sie...
Ihre Schwester.
Und dann muss man aufpassen, nicht dass man das versteht, dass es die Schwester ist.
Sondern die Patientin.
Okay.
Normalerweise, dass man sagt, dass das wie die Patientin jetzt wieder weitergeht.
Weil nicht, dass meine Leute denken, dass es die Schwester ist.
Also die Schwester leidet an alter Hyptopitopien.
Und sie ist Hausfrau.
Sie ist Schwester.
Nein, nein, die Patientin. Die Patientin ist Hausfrau.
Okay, Walter.
Okay, verstehe.
Und Frau Schmidt ist Hausfrau und verheiratet.
Und Sie haben zwei Tochter.
Und Sie lebt mit Ehemann zusammen.
Ihre Ehemann.
Ja, Ehemann zusammen.
Ihrem Ehemann.
Zusammen.
Nicht Eh, sagt man nicht Eh.
Eh, einfach nur Ehemann.
Ehemann.
Ja, okay.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, ich habe Probleme mit Set.
Ja, genau.
Also einzige Problem ist Set.
Ich weiß.
Deswegen mein Name beginnt mit Set.
Und ich weiß, Set ist sehr, ja, einfach sehr.
Ja, okay. Aber das ist im Türkei schon so.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ja, sehr schwer.
Wenn man sich vorstellt, kann man sagen, es wird mit Set geschrieben,
aber es wird mit die scharfes S ausgesprochen.
Das heißt, mein Name wird geschrieben mit Set, aber wird ausgesprochen, sylal.
Ja, das muss man sagen.
Das ist ein scharfes S.
S, ne?
Und das, ja, sehr gibt es im Deutschen.
Scharfes S.
Also, und da muss man sagen, es wird zwar mit Set geschrieben,
aber es wird mit S.
Sylal.
Ja, genau.
Okay, alles klar.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Was hat die Patientin?
Was haben Sie mit der Patientin alles gemacht,
was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, also, also ich habe die Patientin
erst als der körperlich untersucht.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Also, die an amnestischen Angaben,
die Leute am ehesten,
auch eine Rhythma und die Sektion,
auch die Sektion hin.
Wie kommen Sie auf eine Auer- und Diagnose?
Ja, also, onmächtig.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall sehr gut,
eine sehr gute Differenzialdiagnose.
Wenn man Bauchschmerzen hat,
dann ist es eine gute Differenzialdiagnose.
Also Sie meinen so einen Bauch-Au-Auten einer Rhythma, ne?
Ja, ja, ich habe eine gute Idee.
Aber bleiben Sie mal noch einfacher.
Sie hat wechselhafte Stühle.
Ja, und als Differenzialdiagnose
kommen die Folgenden im Betracht.
Also, das kann,
das kann
upon the cities sein.
Ja, das kann sein.
Oder etwas,
ja, upon the cities.
Aber wenn Sie denken, aber ganz ehrlich,
wenn Sie jetzt ganze Zeit den Verdacht hatten,
dass das ein obturiertes Bauch-Au-Auten-Aurysma ist,
ja oder so, ja,
warum haben Sie denn dann so lange noch das Anamnese-Gespräch geführt?
Wenn Sie Verdacht haben, es könnte ein Aort-Au-Aurysma,
eine Aort-Aurysma,
können Sie das denn ganz schnell ausschließen?
Was können Sie denn machen als Untersuchung?
Ja, als der Muss sich einen EKG schreibt.
Ja, EKG schreibt man,
wenn man Verdacht auf den Herz infarkt
oder Torakalis Aort-Aurysma,
weil das sieht man nicht EKG ja nicht.
Ich, das EKG, okay, EKG ist nicht schlecht,
kann man immer machen,
aber bei dieser Patientenhandel ist es ja hier um den Unterbau.
Mal ganz ehrlich, glauben Sie, dass die Patientin
bewusstlos geworden ist,
weil sie ein Aort-Aurysma hat?
Ein Bauch-Au-Aut-Aurysma schmerzt?
Ja, Bauch-Au-Aut-Aurysma, ja, ich glaube...
Unterbauchschmerzen macht ein Bauch-Au-Aut-Aurysma
unter Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, ich glaube, der Oberbauchschmerz.
Mehr als das Torakale.
Und mal abgesehen davon.
Was denken Sie, was das für eine Art von Synkope ist,
was sie hatte?
Wir gehen ja davon aus, dass es eine Synkope ist.
Die hat ja eine Retrograde amnesie.
Retrograde amnesie heißt Synkope.
Okay, was für eine Synkope ist das Ihrer Meinung nach?
Übrigens, diese Patientin liegt bei mir auf der Station.
Das ist alles, was ich erzählt habe, genauso, was ich erzähle, ist passiert.
Was denken Sie, warum die Patientin Synkopeiert ist?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, Reflex oder...
Was ist Reflex? Wie nennt man Reflex?
Oder ich glaube, eine Mühe sein, deswegen.
Nein, das habe ich nicht gefragt.
Was für Synkopen kennen Sie?
Okay, jetzt gehen wir mal ein bisschen tiefer rein.
Jetzt sind Sie selbst schuld.
Jetzt müssen Sie mir genau sagen, was für Synkopen Sie kennen.
Ja, Synkopen, Schock, Zeichen oder was?
Nein, wenn Sie mir mal zwei Oberbegriffe, die wichtigsten Synkopen, die Sie kennen,
die zwei wichtigsten Oberbegriffe.
Es gibt zwei Gruppen, die oft ausbitten.
Was für eine Synkopen Gruppen gibt es?
Ich will nur die zwei wichtigsten wissen.
Was sind die zwei wichtigsten Synkopen, die jeder wissen müsste?
Schock bedingt anophilaktischer Schock,
toxischer Schock, und Kardiage-Adiogena-Schock,
Hypovolemashock, alles klar, das meine ich nicht.
Was gibt es noch für zwei große?
Das haben Sie eben schon gesagt.
Nein, erst mal.
Gott sei Dank, aber hier steht es.
Das haben Sie abgeguckt.
Was ist die häufigste Synkope?
Die allerall häufigste Synkope?
Ja, die wasso vagale Synkope ist die häufigste Synkope.
Was ist die nächste Synkope, die wir kennen?
Die zweit häufigste?
Synkope.
Autostatische Synkope.
Wasso vagale, autostatische Synkope.
Und dann kommt der Rest, Schock bedingt.
Okay, sceptischer Schock zum Beispiel.
Egal, das wollen wir nicht schocken.
Das ist um Sie egal.
Aber jetzt wasso vagale Synkope.
Wenn die Patienten überlegen, sie mal,
so starke Schmerzen hat.
Und die meisten Patienten, wie Sie wissen,
Synkopieren auf der Toilette, immer fast.
Entweder meistens wann, was ist die häufigste Synkope?
Wann synkopieren die immer?
Wenn Sie Stuhlgang haben.
Das ist eine typische, klassische wasso vagale Synkope.
Aber diese Patientin ist vor dem Stuhlgang synkopiert.
Ist das keine wasso vagale Synkope?
Nein.
Doch, warum?
Weil sie so starke Schmerzen hatte.
Das ist reflexbedingter.
Sie hat so starke Schmerzen,
dass sie eine wasso vagale Synkope erlitten hat.
Schmerzbedingte Synkope, eine wasso vagale Synkope.
Sie hat gesagt, die Schmerzen waren unerträglich.
Also, das wissen wir ja aber allerdings nicht.
Deswegen, hätte man sagen können,
die Patientin hat möglicherweise im Rahmen der Schmerzen,
Schmerzbedingte eine wasso vagale Synkope erlitten.
Und sie beschrichtet über wechselhafte Stuhlgänge,
hat ein bisschen Gewicht abgenommen.
Aber sie weiß es nicht genau, das ist nur eine Vermutung.
Differenzialdiagnostik.
Ich nie sagen am ehesten, das wissen wir nicht.
Differenzialdiagnostik kommt jetzt in Frage.
Ganz einfach.
Darum Entzündung, die Vertikulitis zum Beispiel.
Das häufigste.
Beginnende Gastroenteritis zum Beispiel, sehr gut.
Die Vertikulitis, Appendizitis, also entzündliche Darmerkrankungen.
Oder aber, was natürlich nicht passt,
zu Kronen, Kuliz, sie hat überhaupt keinen Blut im Stuhl gehabt.
Und bei Morbus Kronen passt es auch nicht.
Warum nicht?
Das können wir ausschließen, weil sie hätte mehr rechtzeitig die Beschwerden,
wenn das das erste Mal auftritt.
Sie ist auch nie operiert voran.
Die meisten Patienten, die Morbus Kronen haben,
haben eine Abhindectomie hinter sich als Fehldiagnose.
Die haben immer rechtzeitig Unterbauchschmerzen.
Das heißt, Morbus Kronen fällt weg.
Sie hat keinen Blut im Stuhl.
Es hat zwar keiner von Ihnen gefragt,
ob die Patientin Blut im Stuhl hatte.
Keiner. Niemand hat gefragt.
Das ist das Allerwichtigste, wenn sie Schmerzen hat.
Das heißt, Kuliz fällt auch weg.
Also entzündliche Darmerkrankungen trotzdem,
die Vertikulitis, Appendizitis, kann trotzdem sein.
Und was kann noch sein?
Aber kein Fieber.
Sie hat keinen Fieber, gar keine.
Genau, Kulomkarzinom.
Und Sie haben gesagt, die Prinzipialität ist natürlich.
Das ist ja auch ein bisschen veröffentlicher.
Deswegen ist sie noch stabil.
Was haben wir, wenn es ein Bauchortnenerisma ist?
Das kann man auch schnell ausschließen.
Der Blutdruck wäre nicht gut.
Dann hätten Sie sagen müssen, wie war denn der Blutdruck?
Der Blutdruck ist bei 160 bei ihr.
Passt nicht.
Sie hat überhaupt keine Schokosymptomatik.
Der Blutdruck ist zu gut dafür.
Wir haben jetzt aufgeschlossen, der Blutdruck ist gut.
Das in Frage, das in Frage, das in Frage.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Und weil ich es nicht weiß, genau, mache ich erstmal ein Bauchultraschalt.
Das ist das Einfachste, was man machen kann.
Oder eine Blutgasanalyse. Warum?
Bei der Blutgasanalyse sehen wir, was es hat.
Ja.
Ja, wenn das erhöht ist, spricht das für Darmgeschehen.
Oder weiß ich, ja.
Und wir sehen sofort den HB-Wert, Blutbild, HB-Hemoglobin.
Und dann wissen wir, ob die irgendeine Blutung hat oder nicht.
Stimmt es?
Also machen wir Blutgasanalyse und dann machen wir, was als nächstes.
Ein Bauchultraschalt. Das geht ganz schnell.
Warum? Was sieht man im Bauchultraschalt?
Bis das CT angemeldet ist, das dauert alles.
Machen wir nicht sofort.
Wenn man erstmal ein Bauchultraschalt, was sehen wir denn im Bauchultraschalt?
Was wollen Sie denn ausschließen?
Also appendicitis?
Nein, das allererste, das erst mal das Schlimmste ausschließen.
Was ist das Schlimmste, was passieren kann?
Haben Sie doch schon gesagt, Bauchortnannerisma.
Wir können das ausschließen.
Wir können freie Flüssigkeit ausschließen.
Es gibt bestimmte Ultraschall-Soneografie, kann man das ausschließen.
Das heißt, wir haben eine Freie.
Und was sieht man noch? Man sieht Darmverdickungen, sieht man gut.
Die Vertikulitis kann man sehr gut sehen.
Jetzt haben wir bei dieser Patientin aber eine Darmverdickung gesehen.
Der Dickdarm, der Entdarm war verdickt.
Also der Sigma war verdickt.
Und was machen wir als nächstes, wenn Sie sehen,
die Vertikulitis, die Sticharschall, Darm ist verdickt.
Was ist das Verdacht, was kann es sein?
Darm verdickt.
Sigma ist verdickt.
Was ist das?
Sigma, die Vertikulitis zum Beispiel, ist verdickt.
Sie machen ein Thema her.
Und können Sie das jetzt näher abklären jetzt?
Was müssen Sie jetzt machen, als nächste Untersuchung?
Als Kolonoscopy und verliebendenfalls.
Nein, nein, City, City.
City-Abdomen.
Was können wir im City-Abdomen sehen?
Erst mal, wir können ein Anonymer ausschließen.
Und dann sehen wir die Divertikulitis richtig.
Und was hatte die Patientin?
Die Patientin hatte eine Divertikulitis 1b, Stadion 1b.
Okay, egal.
Und dann, was geben wir jetzt?
Was kriegt ihr noch?
Ich habe eine Fieber.
Normalerweise haben Sie Fieber, hat sie nicht.
Aber was geben wir noch?
Ja, ich habe Ultraschall und City.
Wir nehmen Blutkultur ab?
Ja.
Und geben was?
Nein, was geben wir?
Was geben wir?
Nein, Medikamente.
Medikamente?
Was kriegt man bei der Divertikulitis für ein Medikament?
Ja, als Destationaraufnahme
und Spasmolitikum.
Was kriegt man?
Schmerzmittel, ja.
Was noch?
Antibiotikum.
Ja, welches Antibiotikum?
Sipronolactone oder Metronidazol.
Metronidazol gibt man.
Und doppelt 2.
Kombination.
Und F-Treaktion.
Und mit dem Antibiotikum.
Über die Vene.
Super.
Das war jetzt sehr gut.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Schlecht ist immer, wenn man sagt, das ist die Diagnose.
Aber die Prymzialdiagnose, das, was Sie gesagt haben, war super.
Ich habe auch daran gedacht, als ich die Patientin gesehen habe.
Aber sie hat gesagt, sie hat so starke Schmerzen gehabt.
Der Blutdruck war gut.
Also habe ich mir gesagt, ein Autonahrosper kann es nicht sein.
Aber es ist so, dass man die Diagnose nicht so gut sieht.
Wenn man das schnell haben will, macht man schnell eine BGA.
Und der BGA hat man sofort ein Habee-Wert.
Und hat auch Laktatwerte.
Dafür war es viel zu stabil.
Die haben ja sofort eine BGA gemacht.
Habee war gut.
Blutdruck war gut.
Also ein Autonahrosper kommt nicht sofort in Frage.
Wir müssen sofort einen Sonografie machen.
Das sieht man frei Flüssigkeit.
Das ist ein sehr guter Fall.
Ich habe mir gedacht, das ist so diese Schmerzen.
Wenn alles andere gut ist,
war wahrscheinlich eine vasovagale Synkope.
Die Diagnose, Hauptdifizialdiagnose,
das könnte auch anders rum sein.
Es hätte auch sein können Bauarten,
Diagnose, Diagnose, Diagnose, Diagnose.
Das ist beides gut.
Diagnose kommt das und das in Frage.
Super.
Gut.
Das war ein komplizierter Fall.
Das ist ein komplizierter Fall.
Aber komplizierte Fälle,
wenn man komplizierte Fälle kann,
kann man die leichten Sachen auch machen.
Eine vasovagale Synkope kann jeder Schmerz machen.
Das ist oft, ganz oft.
Aber wenn man Schmerzen hat und Synkopiert,
muss man natürlich auch immer einen Ort machen.
Okay.
Ja, deswegen habe ich so gedacht.
Das war gut.
Wir hätten die Prüfung so auch bestanden.
Ich habe das, dass Sie etwas achten müssen,
das Sprach ist sehr gut.
Das hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Bei der Anamnese muss man noch etwas tiefer gehen.
Bei Darm-Sachen, Blut im Stuhl.
Und im Stuhl haben Sie schwarzen Stuhl.
Wie ist der Stuhl dunkel?
Was meinen Sie mit dunkel?
Schwarz oder braun?
Dass Sie wissen, dass es okulzes Blut sein kann.
Aber ansonsten war das ganz gut.
Und z.
Z.
Leider, ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist ja.
Für das die ersten 10 Monate in Deutschland sind,
war das wirklich sehr gut.